it's the Battle of the billionaires and
now it's Mike Bloomberg's turn he used
to be a Republican but he became so rich
he had to join the Democrats he's rich
he's white he's male or in CNN terms
he's Satan now he bloviate sin the faces
of other dams offering wisdom based on
his decades of success as well as being
really boring in earnest while speaking
in New Hampshire he reminds the Dems
that the election takes place in America
not Berkeley with their lame platitudes
the Democratic campaign resembles a
high-school beer party before mom and
dad unexpectedly show up I'm a little
bit tired of listening to things that
are pie-in-the-sky that we never are
going to pass I'm never going to afford
people aren't going to overnight give up
their jobs if those jobs happen to not
be on the right side of the green who do
I think you can have Medicare for all
for people that are uncovered to replace
the entire private system where
companies provide health care for their
employees would bankrupt us for a very
long time talk about charisma or
opposite of charisma don't have him
stand in front of machines because he
just blends in so Bloomberg is calling
BS on his own side offering a reality
check to a party riddled with dopey
history of verse chuckle buckets now
that makes two billionaires image
Schultz throwing cold water on these
bozos they almost make one Trump but
this is a party tied in knots with the
loudest voices embracing bad ideas that
left behind a century's worth of skulls
as progressives aren't they supposed to
look forward instead of dressing up as
Vlad Lenin rejecting the common American
dream they look at this country and say
I'm tired of all this prosperity let's
destroy the greatest system ever created
and replace it with the thing that
always fails
which is why blooming reminds people
that socialism isn't some cool new thing
a hip teacher told you about to get you
to share is bong in a van behind the
football field we need a healthy economy
we shouldn't be embarrassed about our
system if you want to look at a system
it's non capitalistic just take a look
at what was perhaps the wealthiest
country in the world and today people
are starving to death that's called
Venezuela Wow sounds like he's handing
some common sense to the Dems which is
like feeding steak to a cactus you know
when we were when I was writing this up
I didn't actually look at listen to the
tape Katie I just read his quotes I
thought wow he's a really good quote
he's a smart dude and then I listened to
him and I go nope well he's not gonna
make this he's not making it put
yourself on 1.5 speed yes he's not going
with the bombastic yeah nicknames like
president rock on with the cory booker
style hands and Spartacus moves I'm not
sure he's gonna make it but I do like
what he's saying about Democrats he had
some good words to say about Venezuela
and the socialism that we're seeing
there I today Alexandria of Casa Cortez
actually attacked Howard Schultz for
being a billionaire and saying that he
needed to get in line so it's funny how
the left likes billionaires when it's
convenient like donations to their
campaign George Soros funding all of
these advocacy groups but when it comes
to their success in the American Dream
and building themselves up from the
bottom as Howard Schultz did Jada is
someone who grew up in Brooklyn housing
complex and then made his way with
Starbucks there telling them to get in
line and saying their American Dream
doesn't count despite them doing it get
in line is what Democrats said about
Alexandria kasnia Cortes when right he
was trying to beat the and she did
handily beat the through hard work and
then gone didn't even show up to his own
debate do you think you know blue Berg
was a pretty good mayor right well
compared to now yeah yeah well any you
know just a rock found at the bottom of
a toilet honestly what is that did you
see today Dave hot people are hiring
private security yeah protect themselves
on the Upper West Side
well anyways did you pull out these
teachers nobody told me something else
so Janus is already talking what do you
do you think that somebody like him is
gonna make any headway I think that the
headway he makes is by
keep
in the party yeah I don't think he goes
to the front of the pack as the their
ultimate nominee but can somebody like a
Howard Schultz or a but Mike Bloomberg
get the Democratic Party like keep them
from going so far left that yeah it's
just unrecognizable what do you think
what do you think do you think he has a
chance or it will anybody listen to him
or is it just like whoever is kind of
trumping charismatic memorable is gonna
be who's gonna be the nominee well I
think people like the fact that Mike
Bloomberg is a thoughtful guy and he has
a lot of money obviously so he can fund
his own campaign and he's gonna get lots
of platforms I mean it right there you
saw at st. Anselm's already up in New
Hampshire so no question he's going to
be you know out there and media
attention in New York he's no in the New
York media likes them so but that's not
the issue the issue is whether or not a
billionaire in an era of tremendous
income inequality is in touch with the
real issues that face the American
people I I was looking up today I said
something like you know was it a you
know huge number 57% of Americans can't
afford a $500 bill in 2019 and so
there's populism the Trump side of it is
by a $500 bill any of the populism on
the far right and populism on far left
Bernie Sanders Donald Trump we've talked
about this before and I think he's out
of touch with that I mean like for
example the criticism of Medicare for
all which is coming from Kamala Harris
mm-hmm well guess what most Americans
support this until they and then they
say well what about you know can I keep
this whatever but the principle a bold
idea that starting a discussion is
supported by most Americans including
most Republican that is a half opinion
and the other half opinion which has
never brought up as how do you pay for
it and then once you get to that the
other opinion goes Jessie would you like
to talk about Bloomberg or would you
like to talk about Howie Schultz I'll do
both Greg Lee would you like me can I
show you something sure anyway it's on
this tape okay from Morning Joe okay
watch what they did to Howie Schultz
because they're trying to protect
Camelot okay Oh Kabbalah how much does
an 18 ounce box of Cheerios cost in 18
ounce box of Cheerios
years ago you asked God yeah you know
like budgets for the VA we're gonna ask
you questions
I don't eat Cheerios I'm sorry okay it's
very much is it four bucks yeah yeah cuz
she just looked looked it up on Google
she does not drink did eat Cheerios for
breakfast well as the reigning
supermarket showdown champion I was very
disappointed in Schultz and I bought
some cereal today that cost $7.99 it was
very expensive organic cereal you bought
it but my body like should be treated
you know only the best for waters here's
what I think what's happening right now
on the Democratic Party is an
intervention and trust me I know about
intervention it's happened a few times I
know when I see it and the the centrists
are making the same arguments the
conservatives have been making about
socialism for decades and this is why it
stings so much and the Democrat
responses shut up billionaire that's all
they have and Schultz and Bloomberg are
coming at the Democrats with genuine
political fellowship these are Trump
haters they want what's best for the
country and you'd think someone that ran
the biggest city in the country it ran
one of the biggest companies in America
knows a little something about supply
and demands and basic economics but
instead the Democrats don't argue the
substance of their policies they don't
say this is how it's gonna work and this
is why it's going to work and there's
that much gonna cost
they just say you're mean for opposing
me so it's bad politics and bad policy
because you're seeding the entire middle
of the country to Republicans and
Republicans don't even have to do
anything and if you look at the policy
of it to say I want to destroy a
trillion dollar industry put everybody
out of work 50% of the country gets
their health insurance through their
company they like it
you take their plans away it's gonna be
Armageddon but you know what's
interesting there or Shultz is already
having an effect his kamala is already
adjusting he's on the defense demons but
she's changing her mind she's going you
know MIT I'm open I'm not gonna ditch
when you go
the big issue here I'm surprised that
you say this jesse is the deficit the
deficits ballooned under Donald Trump
where did Republicans come in saying oh
this is how we're gonna pay for this
huge tax cut and increase